our common currency the euro
builds bridges between europeans and
opens doors to the world
maybe you also remember this feeling
when we held the euro bills in our hands
for the very first time
i saw a bridge on one side
and a door on the other side
a bridge and a door
both are symbols for europe
symbols for our union
the euro builds bridges of cooperation
and fair competition in our single
market a market that has flourished in
these 20 years as never before
and the euro opens doors to the world
we are the biggest player in world trade
and nearly half of this trade takes
place in euros
the stability of the euro
is treasured around the world
our common currency is a true symbol
for the strength of europe
the euro also reflects our values
the world we want to live in
it is the global currency for
sustainable investments
30 of next generation eu
our recovery plan is earmarked for
investments in the climate transition
the european union is set to become by
far the biggest issuer of green bonds
and we can all be proud of that
and i'm sure that this pride will also
be reflected
in the design of the new euro bills that
the ecb is preparing for
i am already looking forward to holding
them in my hands